Liv welcome to the future of Life
Institute podcast it's great to have you
on
keep having me many of my listeners will
know you but for those who don't perhaps
you could introduce yourself I
originally
studied physics well astrophysics in
particular had plans to become a you
know a researcher I really really loved
physics and particularly anything to do
with space and the universe but
those plans weren't kind of awry when I
took a took some time off to try and
just you know explore the world a little
bit um and I started uh playing on TV
game shows and uh because I always just
loved games and I always thought I'd be
good at them and it was on one of these
game shows that I learned to play poker
I loved poker so much that I then put
physics on holds but see if I could
become a professional poker player so I
ended up being a professional poker
player for
and years or so but during this time I
also got interested in philanthropy my
some other poker players and I started
an a fundraising organization
um for highly cost effective Charities
called raising for Effective giving
and during the course of that I started
to learn more and more about global
catastrophic risk existential risks um
particularly those posed by emerging
Technologies and then I
sort of got so passionate about this
well and also I you know I at some point
started falling out of love with poker a
little bit so I ended up retiring about
in 20 well technically 2019 but I kind
of stopped playing in 2018 and now work
kind of full time as
kind of I guess a sort of science
communicator and and
filmmaker to raise awareness of
some of the like game theoretic drivers
the risks that our civilization is
facing and then particularly the
mechanism that's driving these risks
um and I mostly do that through my
YouTube channel and other social media
platforms
and this leads nicely into the main idea
for for this podcast which is Morlock so
what what do we mean when we say when we
say molok what is that yeah so it's kind
of an esoteric concept
um in that well so it was originally you
know comes from this old Bible story
where
Legend has it there was this horrible
cult who wanted to win so badly you know
win win Wars and and expand their power
so badly that they would sacrifice the
thing they loved the most to this demon
god called molok and that was their
children
um so really really awful uh so it
became known as this like God of War and
sacrifice uh pretty nasty things but
then more recently uh in in popular
culture it sort of re-emerged again
first of all through the silent film and
Metropolis that was made in 1927 uh
which sort of talked about this
seemingly Utopian city that underground
was driven by this sort of dark scary
machine that consumed
workers in order to keep everything
running and the protagonist sees this
machine as as the the god molok
um and then Alan Ginsberg wrote a poem
about it in the 1960s sort of seemingly
comparing it to something akin to
capitalism but there's something else as
well and then Scott Alexander uh of
slate style codex wrote this amazing
blog post called meditations on mollock
which dissected Alan ginsberg's poem and
that was the first time that it ever got
sort of directly linked to a dark force
of Game Theory and of of coordination
failure and race to the bottom scenarios
I'm now trying to sort of popularize
this meme through videos because you
know I think it's such an important
concept
um and I don't see anyone talking about
it on video so that's sort of its uh
story arc of how it became known in
popular culture but what it actually is
therefore you know I don't necessarily
think it's actually like a conscious
demon god that's causing all the world's
problems but in effect it is
the the game theoretic forces uh that it
sort of constitutes
um really are causing many of our big
problems yeah I think it's nice to take
a couple of examples here and one
example you've brought to my attention
at least is this issue of beauty filters
on social media so perhaps explain how
Beauty filters is an instance of a molok
type situation
I you know I I'm a person who uses
Instagram probably too much
um and particularly you know five ten
years ago when I was still trying to
like build my profile and you know I was
trying to make it as a sort of trying to
build Fame as a poker player
there was a lot of I noticed that if I
posted a picture that's with some you
know as sort of a pretty picture that's
not necessarily of myself and that had
some kind of in intellectual content it
wouldn't get that many likes whereas if
I posted a sexy picture of myself it
would get tons of attention and likes
and I was like huh interesting
um and then a few years ago they started
releasing these these AI Beauty filters
that would you know just sort of subtly
tweak and enhance your face you know not
like a form of digital makeup almost
like a form of digital plastic surgery
and I remember like trying these out and
then noticing you know I would input a
picture of myself that I already liked I
thought I looked cute in but then after
I passed it through the filter
I would then like compare the side by
side and I just I would hate the old
photos so basically it would make me
hate my natural face
and yet again I noticed if I posted
pictures with the filter on they would
get even more likes and more attention
and then I noticed that clearly other
influencers were using these things too
and so this you know got me thinking I
was like oh this is a perfect
manifestation of this molok thing
because you know what the way it works
is is basically if you're in some kind
of competitive situation so in this case
you know you're trying to out-compete
other influencers on Instagram to get
more you know more likes more followers
um you know because it's ultimately it
is a bit of a zero-sum game that's going
on there then you're incentivized to use
whatever tricks you can and in this case
this is the ultimate hack some reason
these these filters hack people's
dopamine and make them click those
pictures as opposed to other pictures
so whether or not you really want to use
these things you are massively
incentivized to do it because if you
don't then all your opponents you know
all your competitors are going to get
more attention and so it creates this
like
sort of Race To The Bottom essentially
where you end up sort of sacrific it
sort of forces you if you want to
continue being competitive you need to
sacrifice more and more of your
integrity and essentially you know
mislead your followers about your
natural appearance and so yeah that's
that's one particular example that I I
you know I made my first video about
um because it's just so current and and
so Salient and there are other instances
of molok on social media for example we
can we can think about uh extreme
politics driving the most uh attention
to to specific people we can think about
short and and intense videos that that
uh again attract a lot of attention but
perhaps it's not the best for people's
attention spans I love what Tristan
Harris calls it he calls it the race to
the bottom of the brain stem which is a
lot of what social media is it just
seems like we found these like quirks of
human dopamine you know by and large yes
people are being more entertained you
know if if something is entertaining
they're more likely to click on it but
just because something's entertaining it
doesn't mean it's necessarily good
for them and if everyone is sort of
doing this and it's like encouraging
like the fact that video content is
getting shorter and shorter and shorter
there are presumably negative
externalities to this in the in the form
of like uh you know addiction shortening
attention spans you know you can't get
nuanced points across in a very short
piece of content but because of like the
competitive incentives of the like
social media game we end up in that
situation anyway yeah so what is it
specifically that makes it a moral type
situation is is it the fact that for
each participant in the game it's
rational for them to use the beauty
filter or to do the the shortest and
most intense uh video possible but if
everyone does that then everyone is is
worse off would that would that be an
accurate summary of the molok situation
yeah exactly that's a very good summary
of it you know you can think of it as
whenever people optimize for winning a
sort of short-term like narrow goal at
the cost of the long-term whole
um so it's a bit into like economics
terms it's it's when you fail to
internalize the externalities of the
competitive process that you are playing
um you know so sometimes like market
failures can be the case you know
pollution is another good example you
have a bunch of clothing factories that
you know are in India
um and you know they're all trying to
get by they're all kind of competing
against each other the you know profit
margins are kind of a kind of thin
everyone is incentivized to you know
let's say you know they could be
responsible and and make sure that they
don't pollute the rivers that they're
sitting on by putting in expensive
filtration systems for example but if
they're operating on such tight profit
margins and these the sort of checks and
balances system is very lacks which is
often the case in a lot of Industries
then each individual Factory owner is
incentivized to just like actually
quietly pollute into the river because
they'll be saving money on that and and
especially then they know you know if
one looks down the road and sees that
one's doing it it's like well we might
as well do it and so on and so the cycle
sort of continues yeah so that would be
an example of like failing to capture
the externalities of sort of the
competition that they're playing in uh
you know they get all the upsides of the
profits and Outsource to the like wider
Commons the the costs of of of that game
that they're in essentially and when we
begin or at least when I began thinking
about Morlock it begins showing up
everywhere so it generalizes far beyond
social media it shows up for example in
science too where you're incentivized to
get uh the maximum amount of citations
for your papers as you're as you
possibly you can and this Perhaps
Perhaps the citations is not exactly
what what is not exactly equal to the
most insightful papers and so you're
incentivized to to game the system to to
get a lot of citations but perhaps that
doesn't produce the the greatest science
so that that's a potentially massive
problem also right it's a bit of like a
good heart's law thing the the moment
you you set up a specific metric for
something you open that metric up to
being gamed by people and it begins to
diverge from what you're trying to
capture with that metric
exactly yeah godheart's law which is
like when a measure becomes a Target it
ceases to be a good measure like that's
an example of that right you know the
measure is all the number of citations
is one way of measuring how how quality
a you know scientific paper is and
that's the way what a journal might look
at but then
once everyone starts optimizing for that
they're not actually optimizing for
science anymore and so it's no longer
actually a good good measure um it's
like corrupts what what the original
goal was what is the difference between
normal competition among people to try
to produce the best social media media
video or the best scientific paper and
then these Morlock situations isn't what
we're describing here simply competition
competition is actually like a more
fundamental thing and that it's a form
of interaction just like you have
cooperation coordination Etc
and
competition is actually just a neutral
thing it just depends on the situation
in which it plays out and the actors you
know the agents within it who are
playing it so you know like a tennis
game you know people often think of most
competitions oh it's just purely it's
like a zero-sum thing right one you know
one person's win is another person's
loss true zero sum can only actually
happen in theory you know like if we
play a game of chess or tennis at the
end of this session uh at the end of
this recording we we might become better
friends we might get fitter or smarter
we might get better at chess it's always
because you know things are causally
connected in this universe there will
always be some kind of externality
and the question is is that externality
positive or negative and molok at least
in my definition molec is essentially
the god of negative sum competition in
other words when competition is
unhealthy and makes the world a worse
place for having existed in the first
place just as it you know it can also be
a very positive thing you know there are
many instances in of competition being
very beneficial for society I mean
arguably a lot of capitalism right like
capitalism has been is compared to
something like communism is is a like
Embraces competition deeply
um as as a main mode of interaction
between you know businesses or
individuals and that it has lifted more
people out of poverty than any other
economic model like massively it's
driven Innovation at a far faster rate
than we've ever seen before let's put it
this way I would much rather live today
on a like low to medium income than a
king 300 years ago like my my life
outcomes are so much better because of
all the Innovations we've created by and
large for capitalism but with all forms
of competition if they're not paid paid
attention to they can end up in a very
negative direction oh another example of
um competition being helpful is
even like in science so I remember going
to CERN a few you know but back when
they were trying to I think they'd just
done the the Higgs boson uh Discovery
but I remember being fascinated about
the fact that they had actually had
different teams working on the Large
Hadron Collider competing teams of
scientists racing against each other to
be the first to discover
um the existence of of the Higgs boson
which was like oh this is unusual
normally I thought science was purely a
collaborative Affair but actually no
they were harnessing the power of
competition to to essentially
Force each other to up their game and it
was a really successful model so with it
smart enough design of the game in the
first place competition can be
enormously beneficial in all sorts of
ways
um but the trouble is is that we don't
necessarily design the system smartly a
lot of the systems we are in have sort
of we've bumbled our way into through
sort of kind of random evolutionary
processes and processes and coming from
all kinds of weird starting conditions
that you know didn't have any in
intention behind the design and perhaps
that's a that's a key point right there
because this might explain why it is
that we can't just refuse to play the
the game or we can't just spot which
situations are negative some and then
not engaged in them because we are
already we already exist in a world with
a lot of systems and so we are in a
sense forced to to engage with many of
these uh systems that have these
molecule type Dynamics what I'm thinking
of here is is for example
if you if you start a social media
account or if you start a career as a
scientist well then it's very difficult
to try to to change that system and if
the system you're you're working within
and if you try to do it you will pay a
price individually and so yeah how do
you think about changing these systems
um yeah that's the like the quadrillion
dollar question there's sort of two ways
you can well okay when it comes to like
systems design you know there have been
instances where you know you get a sort
of critical mass of people to appreciate
that the system is is broken that
they're in
um you know like
take take the
the the publication crisis in science
right where
you have
all the sort of prestige locked up in a
small handful of journals that are able
to sort of dictate exactly how science
is done but that then like comes at the
cost of you know like elsevier or
whatever their name is you know their
own so many of the science journals
they don't pay the scientists that
produce the work
they they and then they charge everybody
including the public to be able to even
review the scientific journals but
because if you're a scientist and you
want your work to be you know if you
want to get funding in the first place
you have to prove that you're able to
get published in the model of the main
journals so they've kind of got this
like weird Prestige capture of the
system that
in many ways it's just like you know
they're this like weird body that is
like extracting so much money out of the
system you know they have some of the
highest profit margins in the world of
like major companies
um it's quite astonishing
and it's incred like there's no way for
any individual actor within within it
any individual scientist to like change
the game but that said if they can make
enough awareness of it and I've seen
like movements happen I'm trying to
think of like a specific example of one
that was very successful but you know if
they got like 52 of scientists to all
come together and be like you know what
this is this is really like we
want open source journals from now on
like we don't we science knowledge
should be free to the to the world
um or at least much much cheaper at
least but you know not thirty dollars
per journal or whatever it is to to like
read read this stuff that would be a way
so like finding a way to coordinate but
the trouble is with like monarchy
systems they're Often by definition
like almost basically impossible to
coordinate in uh an example I always
like to give of like a really classic
one is um
like a stadium full of people
um you know let's say you're you know a
football game or a rock concert or
something
and everyone is sitting down you know
when the when the when the game begins
and everyone's got roughly a sort of
equal view because it's like an angled
thing so you know you've got like this
much this much view but then a few
people near the front decide that they
want and actually they want an even
better view they stand up they can now
see wow like it's even further uh
because they're above everyone else's
head so much so they stand up and then
that forces the people behind them well
now if they want to sort of continue
playing the game in this case like just
continue watching the game
um they also have to stand up but that
affects people behind them and so on and
so eventually like almost everyone ends
up standing because of the actions of a
few people at the front because it's so
loud and there's like thousands of
people it's almost impossible to get
everyone to coordinate and sit back down
again so that's an example of like just
a really
explored system that is incredibly
vulnerable to the sort of selfish
actions of just a very small number of
competitors within it to like sort of
cause the whole thing to sort of like
crumble down into this like lower shitty
State because the thing is once everyone
is standing up
that no one's actually now got a better
view than they had before comparatively
but they're all in a worse State because
now they have to stand for the like the
next three hours
um so it's it's like a new equilibrium
they're in a sort of Nash equilibrium
before that was unstable and now they're
in a new Nash equilibrium but it's it's
just worse than the one before it's like
what you would call um elieza yadkowski
wrote a really cool
um book on this called inadequate
equilibria which is just like basically
the the list of just like really shitty
examples shitty equilibrium within our
civilization within our society that
we're kind of stuck in and that it's
almost impossible to coordinate out of
in order to get to where we would be
better off and what's what's so devilish
about these monarchy type situations is
that it doesn't it doesn't require
um that the participants are dumb it
doesn't require that the participants
are evil it's it's simply it feels
almost like you're being forced into
doing something that's that you deep
down know is bad with with your um your
example with the stadium where where you
your incentivized to stand up for
example right you know that people you
know you're throwing the people over
behind you but at the same time you're
being screwed if you don't stand up and
it's like well what am I going to do
we're all going to end up there same
thing with the beauty filters I don't
want you know I didn't want to use them
but if I don't I'm getting you know left
sort of a left behind you know or like
even more perhaps a better example is
like a model a professional model you
know does she does Beauty shoots
and it becomes it became the norm you
know 20 years ago when Photoshop existed
to like have your photos retouched and
let you know even if she's like really
morally against this she's like no
you're like airbrushing my skin so much
it doesn't even look real if she refuses
the the photographers or the the company
or whoever will just hire another model
that will and so she'll be literally out
of work so if she wants to work then she
has to do it it doesn't mean she's evil
it's just like the the setup the game is
evil and then there's this question of
how did we stumble into all of these
systems that are not optimal for for all
of the people who are participating
participating in these systems could we
start new systems if we can't reform the
systems we have could we potentially
start new ones potentially yes
um and in many cases you know I think
I think we're gonna have to but like
when it comes to like the really big
ones you know like our market failures
for example where we've got because
right now
certain capitalistic Industries are not
doing a good job of internalizing their
externalities but at the same time like
I don't think we can just like tear it
all down and start again like we clearly
can't do that it's just way beyond our
scope and it might that tearing down
process may be even more disruptive you
know deadly
um than if we just left it going
um so that would be uh you know with
those kind of problems you kind of have
to do these
and that's where you need like a bit
more like centralization like for
example some smarter rules you know like
if
if you can impr if you could properly
price the cost of polluting the air
or polluting the water then that would
internalize those externalities and
force those companies to actually
um not you know not do the sort of
shitty defection thing but yeah in terms
of like in an Ideal World we would sort
of redesign the system uh so that you're
not having to sort of slap these
Band-Aid Solutions on yeah and then of
course there's the other approach which
is like making people sort of
essentially you know less selfish
because a lot of time people do stuff
where they just it's not because again
they're meaning to be even selfish it's
just they're not even aware that they're
producing externalities they're not
aware that they're polluting The Columns
or whatever
um or they're not aware that they're in
this like race to the bottom spiral and
that's that's sort of why the tactic I'm
taking in like making these videos and
so on and like trying to make them as
like digestible to a really really wide
audience
um because you know I see a lot of
people particularly with like the
political division and everything that's
sort of getting worse and worse
it there's so much like so much of that
is coming from people thinking that it's
all the other the other side's fault if
people go and learn to sort of take a
wider step out and realize that it's
actually you know the system you know
the the let's call it the click bait
industrial complex for example you know
realize that that's actually the Real
Enemy here yes sure the other side they
still do stuff you don't like and so on
but
if you could get out of the haze of the
Indus the clickbait industrial complex
and and see the other side for like
actually the points that they're at
instead of seeing this like really
perverse like villainified version that
the media show you it would reduce so
much of that so trying to get people to
appreciate that like
what the true enemy is is another
approach
um you know through awareness
um and so in those instances where
people do at least have somewhat of a
choice to not do the selfish action or
at least be aware of doing it um
then you know that would also mitigate
and slow down the problem so on the
individual side you have this nice
Counterpoint to malark where another
what do you call it molok is a demon
what is win-win yeah so well yeah so you
know I've been spending I've been
dressing up as molok and so on which uh
after a while starts to get get a little
bit like icky
um and I was thinking okay so if Malik
is the god of negative some games
what's the inverse of that what's the
anti-malog
um who's the god of positive some games
uh of win-win situations and I couldn't
basically think of a better name than
win-win well I started calling it
win-win as a like sort of okay that's
like it's working title but the more I
kept thinking of it the more it just
stuck and now I actually just really
love the name because it's super simple
um it's not like overly fancy but you
know what what it is at its core is is
it's something that loves both
coordination and cooperation you know it
definitely supports whereas Molly hates
that like well
it recoils from the idea of people
getting along and coordinating and
working together on a common goal so it
loves that but it also loves pockets of
competition it loves to have a game it
likes you know when there's space to do
it and the externalities are properly
accounted for
um it will love a nice healthy
competition just like you know they had
at Sun so it's you know it's not like as
Gods go it's not like it doesn't take
itself too seriously it's not like all
somber and like oh you must you know
follow me it's like it's just like down
to party and um and it loves it a good
positive sum game and another thing you
know I try and I try and avoid avoid
calling it The anti-malek because in
reality it's that would put it on like
the same level
uh as Mulligan it's it's something
higher dimensional than that just by Def
you know mollock is because it can only
operate in the realm of competition
whereas win-win can operate in
competition and coordination and it it's
so sometimes it's even so smart and wise
it can even like let go and I can't find
have your little negative sum game right
there yeah go for it but then it is able
to notice when that negative sum game is
getting a little too big and slap it
down so it you know it's it's the boss
of mollock and this is this is just a
way of thinking in in our heads about
which games we are playing in life are
we playing games that involve molok are
we playing games that involve win-win uh
how have you have you found this
personally useful to to think in in
these times
sort of
personally helped me
is well first of all right
like side
you know oh
should I carry on doing videos maybe I
should start a company maybe I should do
something else that you know the first
thing I now ask myself is like well okay
uh what are the externalities of this
going to be is this what win-win would
do you know so that is a sort of
starting point uh just you know and it's
I'm not to say that I can perfectly
model what win-win would do far from it
but just as a as a practice question you
know as a question that I will ask
myself before I undertake something but
another way it's it's
been very helpful for me personally is
I've always been an incredibly
competitive person like like to the
point of of almost pathological when I
was a teenager like I had to be the best
at sports
I would want to know what my friends got
in exams to know you know was was my
percentage was my grade higher and and
this you know this was it you know in
some ways that can be helpful because it
can give you you know
give you the impetus to work harder and
so on but
looking back on it like I know that it
was unhealthy because it would also give
rise to jealousy like if someone did
better than me I would actually feel bad
which is deeply monarchy very very
monarchy you know win-win would be like
good for you you did well great oh I'm
also going to use that as an incentive
to work harder but they were truly you
know Malik feel sorry win-win feels deep
conversion and joy at someone else's
success whereas Malik definitely does
not and
since I've sort of like built this this
you know this a vision of this character
in my in my mind and like you know I try
and emulate it whenever possible and I
found it's made me just you know I now
have a much healthier relationship with
competition if I see you know if someone
goes out and starts their own win-win
thing I will truly feel good about it
because it's like great this is what
this is a positive meme this is a race
to the top more win-win stuff everywhere
whereas I think old me would have been
like it's my thing you know so uh yeah
that's how it's like personally
personally helps me basically so what
we're talking about here is simply
understanding the incentives that we are
working under and understanding how
important it is to to look at the
incentives you are you're operating
within because they will shape you in in
ways that that you perhaps don't fully
understand and that's on the individual
level is there anything to say about the
systems level or the societal level what
could we do to have better incentives to
have less Morlock and more win-win
that's a very broad question I know but
uh is there anything is there anything
you've come across that's interesting
there yeah I mean again it's it's it's
really hard and I I don't have the on
the answer to this
um I mean my I mean my first Port of
Call would be to recommend do I think oh
like they're really good systems
thinkers and are actively working on on
incentive design
um some examples are Ezra Raskin and
Tristan Harris at Center for Humane
technology
um you know particularly through
looking at this these problems how they
manifest in
Silicon Valley
technology and then also Jordan Hall and
Daniel schmachtenberger who are sort of
coming from a an even broader
perspective from like a really
philosophical
um background uh they are some of the
best thinkers on that
throw in my two cents
I think at least for the time being
you know it's not a fully complete it's
not again it's more of like a temporary
Band-Aid solution to these to these
problems but uh things like having
you know nuclear weapons treaties
have historically you know they've
probably kept us alive in the last few
decades we might we probably wouldn't be
here if we didn't have some kind of
treaties a really strong International
Norms against the use of nuclear weapons
while you know they're not completely
fixing they're not making nuclear
weapons go away they are at least giving
us buying us time to figure out the
solutions to these like tricky game
theoretic dilemmas
um so yeah having stronger Norms like
basically
where people where we where Society has
a better immune system against defectors
you know whether it's through social
punishment actual you know uh
uh restrictions or whatever uh that's
that's definitely a good starting point
yeah the other thing I would say is but
you know the reason why I'm like trying
to raise awareness of this issue is
because we need as many smart people
to understand the nature of the problem
that we're in that we're in like
basically an incentive design problem
and the more smart people you know put
their minds to that as opposed to
figuring out how to like extract extract
more dollars on the margin of whatever
thing they're trading or you know then
the the faster we will come to a better
solution of this so
yeah I hope that kind of answers it so
maybe a question here to to just turn it
around on itself is to ask how do we
incentivize people to think about our
incentive incentive design is there
anything we could do here should we have
prices for coming up with the best
incentive designs yes that's a good idea
um hadn't considered that yeah like the
annual win-win prize
who came up with the best cool new
positive sum competition you know that
aligns the incentives of of the
individual with the whole that's
actually a really cool idea because I
don't think we have you know we've got
like analogous ones like oh you know
the Nobel Prize right that is awarding
someone who has expanded the the
frontier of human knowledge which is
definitely a win-winning action that's
an example of like incentive like you're
providing some form of competition you
know people are competing for a Nobel
Prize to an extent but it's with a
thoroughly positive externalities but we
haven't got one that's explicitly saying
this you know that is explicitly about
like systems design incentive design uh
on really hard coordination problems
like whoever
ends up fixing
coordination problems for good deserves
the prize of all prizes that is that is
the ultimate Universal price uh at least
from my perspective so yeah that would
be one way do you actually think there
is such a solution do you think
coordination problems are solvable in a
fully General sense or is it something
that will always be with us just because
there are limited resources in the
universe almost no matter how wealthy we
become
definitely molok thrives on scarcity you
take away scarcity it's going to be
really hard for it to get its teeth into
anything
um so
all the while we have some degree of
scarcity of something that people want
then there will probably see
coordination problems arise mostly race
to the bottoms arise
so my logical brain says
no we can't but my intuition says that
actually we can I think women would be
like oh we can absolutely solve this so
I'm gonna
throw that out there too what's an area
of research that you would be most
excited about in in terms of incentive
design so we we've mentioned social
media we've mentioned science we've
mentioned nuclear weapons what's
something that's that's extraordinarily
important and you would you would like
people to research from the incentive
design perspective well the one that's
most on my mind right now is the AI arms
race
you know we're really watching that play
out right before our eyes right now
um where certain labs are being more
lucky than others you know they're all
in a in in a competition for
you know funds the market share or
Talent
you know they all want to have the best
researchers and developers and so
they're all in this again and they're
all playing the game of like
you know they're all facing the the you
know the moral dilemma of like oh I
probably should this model isn't quite
ready to release so probably shouldn't
release it to the general public yet but
if we don't then those guys are going to
do theirs first and so on so it's
another classic example of this
and
I
personally think that
it's something you know we need to turn
down the competition dial on the you
know I would love for us to develop
super intelligence you know and and I
think AI could be one of the best things
that we ever invent it might even help
us solve coordination problems but at
the same time right now molik is getting
into the development of it and that is a
really big problem arguably the biggest
problem that we're facing and we've got
a lot of big ones uh so if people can
put their minds to that you know how do
we improve
through coordination between the
different competitors essentially trying
to race to build AI how do we develop
better Norms to
incentivize these these labs and
companies for you know to to not defect
to to actually you know make make
it so that alignment is
is much closer to you know to progress
uh or at least yeah I don't know it's it
that is definitely the the most pressing
manifestation of molok in our in our
world right now and I think the more
people who can put their minds to it the
better our chances are of
solving if not just mitigating it how
much is Humanity leaving on the table in
terms of gains we could have if we could
avoid all of these molecule type
situations
um how much better could the world be if
we could coordinate in a in a more
healthy way
a lot I can't quantify that
but the the you know the the answer will
be in like
multiples presumably of all GDP you know
just because there's so many
it's costing it's just making so many
inefficiencies and again just like we're
getting to the stage now where we are
literally able to alter the climate of
the planet that
produced us and we need uh uh we're
built weapons that are so powerful that
they could
literally destroy everybody on Earth
there's there's so much essentially like
value you know it's like negative value
that we're producing that we could get
rid of and like add into our future
light cone that could lead into
potentially Millennia of human
flourishing or whatever our descendants
are whether they're digital or or
natural it just seems like an absolute
tragedy that we are not
putting all of our minds to figuring out
how to solve you know how to gain
control of our evolutionary path because
right now we are not in control of our
own evolution of our own destiny in you
know individually we might be able to
control Our Lives to an extent but
um as a collective we're not doing a
particularly good job of that but I
think we can if if we just put our minds
to it what do you mean by the by us not
controlling our Evolution as a species
well it just seems like
we
we're just sort of following along with
whatever incentives that have been
dangled before us you know we're we're
still operating on the same
wet wear that we had 150 000 years ago
more or less
and
while our brains are incredible clearly
they the landscape in which we they are
operating is so fundamentally different
to what it was back then
we're just like clearly a little bit out
of our depth you know even even the most
ardent
accelerationists I think are like are
aware that there are some things that
like could be dangerous you know and
they're like whoa okay
if if you know if we don't
make a conscious effort to like build
the morality you know but figure out
what like values and principles we want
to go into our technology and instead do
it the other way around and let
technology just build the technology
first and then see what arises from it
then we're not in control of our own
destiny you know like technology is
driving us the the wheels are driving us
um and to some extent therefore Mollica
is driving us we need to sort of reverse
that stack we you know like a good
friend of mine described you know
monikers like if you let Technology
Drive social structures which then drive
memes that's where you get more look
because technology is not values neutral
it can absolutely affect what what
philosophies and principles we have if
we don't consciously guide it and
win-win is the other way around come up
with your values come up with your memes
let them give rise to human social
structures that are like honoring those
things and from there build the
technologies that you need to better
like you know make your lives better
um so we just need a little bit more
conscious intention behind the
technologies that we build we don't just
you know do it because we think it's
going to be most profitable or get us
the most Fame what do you say to the
people who are who are not interested in
it in in trying to slow down and trying
to to think about how we want to steer a
technology what do you think of the
people who are who are simply interested
in accelerating technology as much as
possible how do they fit into to this
whole
um social uh structure and incentive
structure the the the the the the
Divergence between what it seems like
you know the views are between for
example AI alignment and the uh AI
accelerationist I don't think the
Divergence is much as much as either
side think the vast majority of AI
alignment people I know
would like to see AGI exist they would
like
technology to exist and for it to be as
democratized as possible you know like
I couldn't think of I think it'd be
horrifying to have some like centralized
World cabal controlling it like that's a
Surefire way towards tyranny like that
that needs to be avoided but at the same
time
unfettered like screw the externalities
just build whatever comes you know
full steam ahead without any like real
attempts to align it with that keeping
it a biosphere alive is also devastating
so we need some third option so that
third option will come from the
synthesis of these two groups
like I think if they hive mind together
there will be the the third option where
it's you know
we get these amazing technologies that
we deserve to have and we should have
and that they are not
you know vulnerable to authoritarianism
and tyranny what I personally love about
like the the accelerationist crew is
like they have like they have so much
optimism about the future and I think
that is sorely needed it's really really
cool that you know the we you know the
weakness in their argument is that it
seems to it seems to be based more on
Vibes sometimes as opposed to like
actual solid understanding of how the
alignment problems work but that's
that's you know that's fine everyone has
a gap in knowledge and everything is
learnable and again like that optimism
is incredibly important to drive the
alignment people to
keep working on on the thing and I think
there's so much like low-hanging fruit
between like knowledge sharing and
information sharing between the two
groups they might appear at odds but in
reality they're not and I think if
actually that's also part of the problem
of like they communicate mostly through
the internet and internet is inherently
like information lossy and and
dehumanizing if they could actually just
get in a room together and like talk
they realize they actually have very
similar goals
or at least like you know they're not
perfectly aligned but they're much
closer aligned than it may appear
through Twitter so you would encourage
them to cooperate and perhaps they could
get to a win-win situation
exactly yes
great that's a that's a great way to end
it live thanks for coming on the podcast
thank you